[Applause]
this time the tears among pro-abortion
rights advocates were of joy
kansas voters provided their first
victory since the u.s supreme court
overturned federal protections for
abortions in june a coalition of voters
across the political spectrum came
together today and voted no they voted
no to protect their neighbors
they voted no on changing the
constitution
and really
you know demonstrated our free state
routes here in kansas are alive and well
voters squashed a proposed amendment to
the kansas state constitution that would
have overturned a 2019 decision
declaring access to abortion is a
fundamental right if abortion rights are
uh are are protected here in kansas and
again republican-leaning state um i
think that that indicates that there is
a big the the states that have those
trigger laws probably are out of step
with what their electorate wants
the kansas decision will have a regional
impact the nearby states of texas
oklahoma and missouri now have bans on
abortion which means women will have to
travel elsewhere to get one it is
unclear what the next move will be for
abortion opponents in kansas
we have to rein in the supreme courts
imposing their opinion and making up a
constitutional right to abortion in our
constitution which isn't there
voters across america will continue to
weigh in at the state ballot box in the
next few months people in california
kentucky and vermont will decide if
women should have access to an abortion
in their state natasha name al jazeera
let's go live now to washington d.c
altitude's mike hannah is there for us
mike we've had that vote then in kansas
what's joe biden doing
well it is in a way a coincidence with
that vote in uh kansas that president
biden is going to be signing an
executive order in coming hours this is
the second such order in recent weeks
essentially what it does is directs the
health secretary to examine ways in
which women safely can cross state
borders for medical care in particular
for abortion so it is more in terms of a
directive rather than a direct order
asking the health secretary to
investigate report back to the president
but this is the white house stepping up
its uh its operations in the wake of the
supreme court decision and it's
significant that the kansas vote has now
come because that gives added uh
ammunition to president biden's efforts
it must be noted too that in the past 24
hours the justice department has signed
suit against the state of idaho because
of their anti-abortion legislation so
there are a lot of moves among the
administration in terms of dealing with
the consequences of roe v wade it must
be noted too that president biden has
also said that he might support the
amendment of the filibuster measure in
the senate which requires more than an
absolute majority to pass legislation to
get congress to pass
anti
to pass abortion legislation or freeing
abortion legislation this is president
biden's point all along that ultimately
he can issue executive orders but in
order for meaningful change to occur in
order for the roe v wade status to be
upheld it's congress that has got to
make the change al jazeera's mike hannah
reporting live there from washington
mike manny thanks indeed